the Star Wars universe is a pretty
complex place and it gets a little more
complex with every episode of rebels
every tie in comic and novel and best of
all when a highly continuity dependent
movie like rogue 1 is released every
tenuous connection makes the experience
a little richer no matter how hard the
director tries to hide these things in
the fabric of the film here are a few
rogue one Easter eggs you didn't notice
oh and if you haven't seen rogue one yet
brace for impact
spoilers ahead blue harvest what is it
with young rebels and blue milk as a
very young Jin escapes her family's farm
at the beginning of Roga Wan we see a
glass of blue milk purse on a countertop
not unlike the questionable beverage
that young Luke Skywalker had to endure
in a new hope the blue mood juice also
appears in attack of the clones
presumably the junk comes from banthus
but no one is free from it even on
planets where banthas aren't a native
species someone is importing this junk
forget about building a deaf star just
corner the blue milk market if you want
to conquer the galaxy where there's a
well back when Star Wars was just a
shadow of an idea and the curly head of
George Lucas it was called Journal of
the Wills the concept of an ancient race
of aliens deeply connected to the force
has floated around the Star Wars
universe since the beginning but nothing
really definitive has been established
about them except for that they
absolutely have nothing to do with
Yoda's unknown species lo and behold the
desert city of Jeddah was actually home
to the temple of the wills once guarded
by the blind chroot my and freelance
assassin Bay's Melba's the bustling
mysterious city has super deep ties to
the whole Jedi thing which is reinforced
by the Fallen Jedi statues around the
surface and the fact that is absolutely
full of Kyber crystals used to make
lightsabers jeddah jedi it can't be a
coincidence and now it's exploded there
not so good doctor
it's a cameo that's impossible to miss
in the ill-fated city of Jeddah jyn erso
and casseon and or bump into a really
really ugly man and his walrus face pal
visitors to Sherman's Cantina on
Tatooine will easily recognize the duo
as dr. Everson and Ponda Baba who tried
to start trouble with Luke's
by Walker and lose an arm to obi-wan
Sabre apparently Ponda Baba could easily
escape a city going totally nuclear but
couldn't keep his arms from falling off
his body in a sleazy bar a few weeks
later tough break buddy the worst job in
the universe directing the ads yet
entitled Star Wars Episode eight would
be a dream job for just about any
director and that you probably know Rian
Johnson scored the gig after directing a
few episodes of Breaking Bad and writing
the screenplay for episode 8 but he also
got the absolute worst gig in the galaxy
standing next to the deadly
planet-destroying rating less laser
shaft in the Death Star
I just want a railing you know one
railing right here yeah I know I've
almost fallen over that thanks so many
times it's a carrier we wouldn't even
know about if Johnson didn't tell us a
2016 Star Wars Celebration in London so
let us not forget that not only did
Galen Urso build a vulnerable exhaust
port into the Deaf star but you subtly
made these guys lives a living hell for
a rebellion budget Deaderick and cave
monsters there are a lot of scummy
things going on in saw Guerrero's
ramshackle Base including but not
limited to watching weird hollow porn of
dancing toilets which only reminds us of
grandpa Ritchie's dirty dances in the
Forbidden Star Wars Holiday Special oh
oh we are excited idly but amid the many
props and baubles found in the base is a
very bootleg version of Deaderick
the holographic chess game found aboard
the Millennium Falcon this dollar-store
version uses actual physical pieces and
not the high-tech animated holographic
stuff which is what you get when you
blow your whole hologram budget on
dancing girls also making an appearance
in Carabas cave and especially Easter
ready form our creatures from director
Gareth Edwards 2010 film monsters at his
2014 film Godzilla the director told the
Star Wars show that it wasn't even him
being cheeky
these were slipped into Guerrero's cave
by the crew like father like son
like all good super villains Darth Vader
has to have a sweet and scary base we've
only really seen him hanging out on
giant starships but early concepts for
the character placed him in his very own
snake Mountain by the name of bass
castle on the beaches of an acid rain
planet called for June where we love
State is probably cheaper than Detroit
while rogue one
flips the script a bit and thankfully
his bass doesn't just look like a giant
version of his own helmet because that
design was stolen by the Legion of Doom
Vader apparently chills on a fiery lava
planet which is presumably Mustafar the
very same place he lost most of his body
parts and caused on fire courtesy of
obi-wan Kenobi because there's nothing
like building a home on the shores of
the lake where humanity and dignity
drowned and of course Vader has to take
his cumbersome costume off occasionally
right we learn that in order to
rejuvenate his half robot body he goes
swimming in his own personal bacta tank
extremely similar to the one we see Luke
in recovering from frostbite and some
serious Whomper wounds though a sassy
Whomper slap is a lot less serious than
you know losing all your limbs the
rebels connection early Intel for
obi-wan was adamant about the film
having nothing to do with the ongoing
animated series rebels but now that
seems like a bit of a misdirection for a
few reasons first it looks a lot like
the rebel ship ghost is spotted among
the fighters during the film's final
battle indicated by the unique pattern
of lights on the rear of the ship there
aren't too many ships buzzed somewhat
like a surprise clown but the ghost is
one of them second the name general
syndulla is mentioned and unless
singular as the Jones or Smith of the
galaxy that would have to be hera
syndulla the captain of the ghost some
viewers have also speculated on the use
of the name black saber as one of the
Empire's projects mentioned as jinn is
searching the archives and just before
she lands on the file she's searching
for star dust while there are a lot of
sabers in the universe the dark saber is
an ancient Jedi artifact when stolen by
the Mandalorians and then wielded by
Darth Maul and yes it has a black blade
black saber could refer to just about
anything though from Darth Vader's tear
owing hellish home to an undisclosed
death weapon to Grand Moff Tarkin
favorite pie recipe time will tell
blasting womp rats Luke Skywalker even
though it one day become a noble Jedi
was a jerk of a kid to quash his boredom
on Tatooine he'd hop into his t16
skyhopper and fly around blasting womp
rats apparently his love of fun is
shared by stormtroopers too since to
helmet heads can be heard on scare if I
delete chattering about how the old c50
models were getting phased out do
stormtroopers go on joy rides or
just an endless nightmare of anxiety
until a rebel blows you up or a slightly
perturbed Darth Vader crushes your
windpipe we hope it's a former red five
the Rebel Alliance existed long before a
shaggy head farm boy turned Jedi came
along to save it well Luke was out
collecting moisture in the desert and
whining about not going to Tashi station
a real rebel soldier was flying around
in an x-wing with the callsign red five
until he exploded during the attack on
scare off' a little while later Luke
would take the same callsign during the
Battle of Yavin destroying the first
dester since you know no one was using
it anymore but he wasn't the only
hotshot pilot and he wasn't even the
boss the head of the red squadron garvin
Dre's survived the attack on scurry and
went on to attack the Death Star at the
Battle of Yavin original actor drew
Henley came back to play the role at
least via some amazing CGI work since
Henley was 76 at the time and passed
away ten months before the film reached
theaters he can consider himself in some
pretty solid posthumous company thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're loved too
[Music]